hey what's up guys mkbhd here and this
is the nexus 7.
we got past the unboxing phase of this
everyone got their packages today and
their unboxings these are my first
impressions of the seven inch nexus
tablet that i am holding in one hand
let's take a look
so just for the record i had no problems
unboxing the nexus 7
and right about 10 minutes after the
first boot it found a system update to
the latest version of android android
4.1.1.js bean and jelly bean as we
already know has a lot of awesome
improvements over the last version of
android like the buttery smoothness of
project butter offline speech to text
and the brand new keyboard in android
and even google voice search and google
now but all these things
are also on the galaxy nexus and even
the nexus 7 and the motorola zoom what
really makes the nexus 7 unique from
other tablets is the form factor see
this is a 7-inch tablet it's got a
1280x800 display it's extremely
lightweight like a paperback book it has
a wide screen aspect ratio a thinner
than average bezel and a default
portrait orientation instead of
landscape all of this is new we haven't
seen this in other android tablets
before and others were mostly 10-inch
widescreen tablets that you hold
sideways with two hands this guy i found
you basically always used it as a
smaller one-handed more portable tablet
now you're gonna hear a lot of people
who can't seem to talk about the nexus 7
without mentioning the kindle fire in
the same breath but the truth is this
isn't even really aimed at the kindle
fire in fact this isn't aimed at any
particular tablet actually at all this
is the first real 7-inch android tablet
as far as we're concerned and in that
google has created a new market with
this device forget the pathetic 7-inch
samsung galaxy tab the original with
gingerbread on it forget the amazon
kindle fire with who knows whatever
version of android it'll never be
updated this is it this is the nexus
this is obviously what google wants
android to be on the 7-inch platform and
this is the definitive android tablet
right now nexus 7 is thinner it's
lighter it has twice the ram a much
faster quad-core processor a
front-facing camera a microphone for
video chats gps nfc a gyroscope a higher
resolution display with a higher pixel
density it's more powerful more capable
and much faster and smoother than the
kindle fire it has a larger app store
and best of all it's virtually
guaranteed the next few years of android
updates this guy is armed to the teeth
like a boss to give you an amazing media
consumption experience calling the nexus
7 a kindle fire competitor
would be an insult to the nexus 7. it is
way beyond that and if you had any
thoughts about google taking massive
shortcuts to hit that magical 200 price
point you can rest easy the only thing
you could possibly find a hitch with is
the lack of a rear-facing camera and the
lack of a removable back which means no
extra storage now you're not taking any
pictures with this tablet so that's one
off the list and google really ramps up
the google play integration the google
play cloud experience so you're really
streaming more things from the cloud
instead of having everything locally i
have the eight gig version and right now
i might not even ever need to upgrade so
there you go this guy is in a league of
its own it is definitely an impressive
device so far go ahead and give it a
thumbs up on this video if you want to
see more videos about the nexus 7 and
leave a comment if you want to know
something about the nexus 7 maybe i
should compare it to a certain other
asus tablet or a certain other
tablet that exists out there maybe you
want to see that kind of video but
definitely let me know what you guys
want to see i'll be enjoying this uh and
messing around with this uh pocketable
kind of not really device uh in the
future so thanks for watching and i'll
talk to you guys in the next video
peace
[Music]
you